what's going on guys welcome back to the
rumor roundup my name is rob and we have
a huge episode for you guys today the
big
thing that everybody is talking about
right now supposedly by his own
admission
james gunn has had conversations with
the head of the marvel cinematic
universe kevin feige and the head of
what passes for cinematic universe at dc
with having a crossover between both
universes that's right the marvel
cinematic universe
meets whatever we call the dc movies
right now
that's an awesome idea i love the idea
of these things crossing over one
because it's great publicity for the mcu
and two because it could save the dc
cinematic universe so i love the idea of
these two things meaning
having said that no idea how that would
happen honestly it only ever happened a
couple times the first time it was
marvel vs dc
and it basically had to do with these
two brothers who essentially forced the
universes to meet with each other after
that there was this weird reality warper
named access and
honestly the entire plot behind it's
kind of ridiculous so if they did it in
movies people would laugh at it they
would probably consider it to be dc's
idea and that would just
sync their cinematic universe even
further while kevin feige was like yes
that is warner brothers idea blame them
so i have no idea what would go on there
but
uh the reality is whenever we saw marvel
and dc
cross over with each other some
relatively cool things came out of it so
the first time it happened
it was really a fan service kind of
thing and in fact what they did
is they had characters from marvel fight
characters from dc
and they had fans determine who the
winner would be and then all the writers
did was just craft how the fight would
go down but seeing wonder woman face off
against storm or seeing the incredible
hulk fight superman
these are cool things that we got a
chance to see eventually you jump into
later on which was
justice league versus the avengers or
jla versus the avengers and that was
kind of a cool concept it really had to
do with the schemings and mechanisms of
stuff going on behind the scenes
but it was actually in that story that
we learned the infinity gauntlet doesn't
work in alternate realities
following that marvel took it and ran
with it and just kind of became an
absolute rule in the marvel universe but
the infinity gauntlet only works in its
native universe but seeing these
cinematic universes meet would pose some
pretty cool stuff but at the end of the
day it's really just hearsay right
there's no factual evidence of this
aside from
what james gunn told us and it could
have been that this casual conversation
he had with them was him
walking into the office and saying hey
how would you feel about crossing over
with dc
or hey how would you feel about crossing
over with marvel as far as the movies go
and their answer is like no
and like that's the conversation we
don't really know right we have no
evidence on this but moving on to our
next topic
jamila jamil has been cast as titania
in the she-hulk tv show it is awesome to
see titania getting some representation
in the marvel cinematic universe i don't
really believe
anything major will come out of it and
if anything they'll probably kill her
character off but if they really wanted
to pursue its course
you could potentially make an argument
that secret wars is coming or may have
already happened or something like that
the reason why i say that is titania
debuted during the secret wars event and
the way this worked is titania was
basically a girl who was kind of
diminutive in size and always longed to
be what amounted to essentially an
amazon and so eventually she got her
wish during the secret wars event when
she was beefed up she was huge and she
was just kind of this
colossus of a woman she was in a lot of
ways in amazon at least only in terms of
physical appearance
eventually she dated crusher creole for
a while they were knocking boots for
quite some time they were kind of on
again off again
but titania is a big woman and she
really is one of the very few
mainstay foes that she hulk has in
reality
i'm not entirely sure how this is going
to go down which really kind of allows
us to sort of sidecar our next topic
which is scar
the son of hulk appearing in she-hulk
i'm not 100 sure how i feel about these
things
and the reason why is because the
she-hulk tv show has been billed
as a half-hour long legal comedy anybody
who's ever read anything about titania
or especially scar son of hulk will tell
you they're about as far from comedic
characters as you can get
here's the thing about scar son of hulk
right scar is basically the incredible
hulk
without the limitless power but the
ability to control the old power which
basically means he can control
earth right like literally tectonic
plates things like that what this does
is it makes scar
a pretty significant character but more
so than that
in terms of just how his character
function he didn't have a funny bone in
his body he was a dick
he was just kind of mean like all the
time but by and large he was just kind
of like one of these characters who
wanted to prove that he was better than
the incredible hulk
just kind of had a chip on his shoulder
all the time but you can tell from this
bit of a description here that there
isn't really a whole lot in terms of
comedy there
and the reality is i don't know how i
feel about titania or scar son of hulk
being depicted in a comedy show because
i don't really believe that we're going
to see them in a serious tone and i
don't really know if we're going to see
anything with regards to like jennifer
walters doing her thing where she's
going through all the legal stuff in a
courtroom and then oh my god the son of
the incredible hulk is attacking the
earth let's go do that and like it
deviates for a whole episode like this
super serious tone
i imagine scar and titania will kind of
be brought in and they'll be a part of
that sort of legal comedy that we see
going on in terms of the feel of the
show and i
don't know how i feel about that i kind
of prefer something a little more
serious with them
i would prefer to see characters like
that when they're actually heavy hitters
when they sort of reflect their comic
book counterparts now it could be that
it's a resounding success and that's why
i'm not really advocating that it's
going to be a disaster
that it's stupid it's a silly idea
because truth to tell
i never really would have believed that
wanda could have held her own tv show
and one division was fantastic so it
really just kind of takes a little bit
of experimentation and it takes a little
bit of just kind of
putting characters in situations you
wouldn't normally see them in to
actually make them a little more
interesting than they were
when they initially appeared most people
don't care about titania and most of you
guys have probably never heard of her
but you know for what you do see she's
not that
interesting but if you put her in the
show and they make her fantastic
things could really get cool from there
so i guess it's really only a matter of
time and we just kind of have to wait to
see what happens
but on to our next topic grant gustin's
flash
is actually going to have a cameo in the
flash film and i'm gonna be honest with
you guys
i always felt like grant gustin would
have made a great addition to the actual
dc cinematic universe film line
i never liked the idea that they cast
ezra miller one because he runs weird
and two
while there is a lot of comedy to his
character if i'm being honest
i feel like grant gustin nails barry
allen almost perfectly
the writing of the show really needs
some work
but as far as like the actual portrayal
of the characters candace patton does an
amazing job as iris west
and grant gustin does an amazing job as
barry allen and i always felt like
having him in the show was a little bit
of like a training wheels kind of thing
right
let's see how grant gustin performs with
the flash on cw and then if he does well
let's put him in the movies and i felt
like that's exactly what should have
happened a lot of that universe was
already built
i'm not really sure i would bring
anybody else along for the ride maybe
harrison wells but that might be about
it
the rest of the cast i could kind of do
with that they're not bad
it's just they don't really seem
essential and so because of that i would
have just
made grant gustin the main flash in the
movie such as it was we ended up getting
ezra miller one thing i am glad to see
we are getting some grant gustin
representation in the movies and what
capacity
we're not entirely sure is told that
we're getting a cameo which means if
that's the case it might be for a minute
or two or it could be one of these
things that because it deals with the
idea of the flashpoint paradox that it
might be just some
alternate reality depiction that we saw
i mean we did see in the crisis on
infinite earth's television event
that ezra miller crossed over with barry
allen in the cw with grant gustin so it
makes sense they would kind of do the
opposite and it may very well be that
it's just kind of a scene that leads
into that scene and that's really it
right it just kind of gives us how we
got to that point
when ezra miller is in the speed force
and he talks to grant gustin and then
just disappears and that's basically it
but i don't know i mean the biggest
issue that i feel like the cw has or
really even just warner brothers has is
their entire cinematic universe feels so
disheveled
and so because of that i feel like just
kind of wiping away all that stuff right
using flashpoint paradox to kind of
clear the landscape say okay we're
basically starting over here
and then making grant gustin the main
flash getting rid of ezra miller i think
is a great idea but again
maybe i'm in the minority here right let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments but maybe i'm in the minority
maybe i'm one of the few people who
thinks that grant gustin would be a
great flash in the at least as far as
the movies go i know that this is a
little bit of a tangent about grant
gustin it's just i'm a huge fan let's
move on to our next topic before i
derail this entire video and go off on
tangents about stuff that have
nothing to do with anything that we're
talking about
[Laughter]
so chameleon is rumored or expected to
be a villain
in the craven the hunter solo film now
here's the thing i've been doing a lot
of reading online and a lot of people
are kind of looking at this like oh my
god sony really a craven film i think
sony's doing something spectacular here
and i think sony's doing what the marvel
cinematic universe has
failed at here's one of the most
important things to understand if you've
read comics for any real measure of time
oftentimes the villains are more
interesting than the heroes
spider-man is okay but whenever i read
peter parker there's only really two big
runs that i like about his character
the first one is dan slott's amazing
spider-man run and the second one is
actually
in dance slots amazing spider-man run
which is when dr octopus takes over the
body of peter parker and you get
superior spider-man
whenever i look at this idea of the
marvel cinematic universe and i look at
the villains right
thanos and the red skull and and all
this kind of stuff even even characters
like dormam
who we'll probably see a little bit more
of baron mordo who basically just
vanished we know he's going to be in
doctor strange too but i look at these
villains that the marvel cinematic
universe has and they kill them off and
it feels like such a waste
if you look at characters like william
striker for example in marvel comics
he's a religious evangelical
fundamentalist who believes
it's his mission from god to kill
mutants so he created the purifiers he
has no powers whatsoever but he is
exceedingly charismatic and that's what
makes him so intriguing magneto
speaks for himself but you see this kind
of stuff all the time
and i feel like sony launching
villain-based films
movies that focus on the stories of the
villains is
great it's a great idea craven the
hunter can be cool sometimes
i guess it really depends on what
particular story that you're reading if
you do read the story where he basically
eats a whole bunch of spiders to try to
give himself spider-man's powers because
he's crazy
as a little wonky but if you read craven
the hunter stories that are akin to like
the most dangerous game right the idea
of the hunter hunting people
then you can get some really really cool
stories out of it you can get a lot of
depth to his character the idea of the
chameleon appearing it's cool
because a chameleon can just become
anybody write a master of disguise a lot
of these villains that are being built
up i feel like are going to play a much
bigger role as far as what sony wants to
do with spider-man but i think it's a
genius idea so i don't really have any
hate for it having said that
chameleons has long since deserved a
role as far as movies go he was the
first villain peter parker ever fought
so i'm kind of surprised that we haven't
really seen a chameleon-centric film up
to this point
i mean a lot of people might say well i
mean you know it's chameleon right how
could you possibly make them interesting
people said the same thing about iron
man and look at we are as far as the
iron man films go so
you can't really write them off at the
end of the day it all comes down to how
the character is written so
i am excited to see the chameleon might
appear in craven i would much rather see
a solo chameleon film depending on how
it's done but at the end of the day
it is a cool thing that we're getting
there so i can't be too upset about it
so our next little bit of news here and
not a whole lot to talk about here
aquaman 2 is officially titled aquaman
and the lost kingdom it may be
that it ties into a lot of the dc
rebirth stuff so it kind of gives us
like the kings of
old and all that kind of stuff but the
first aquaman film was a little too
fast and the furious for me in terms of
how it was shot and how it felt having
said that it was still good
but i don't want to be one of these guys
who's just like everything sucked
it was still a pretty good movie it was
certainly one of the best films that dc
had released in a long long time
but i am excited to see what this does
turn into one of the funny things about
aquaman there's a lot of history and a
lot of mythos there right there's a lot
of stuff that goes on with the
characters so
if they tell it right they can really
give us a lot of the old
stories with regards to like aquaman
arthur curry and a lot of the history
that goes in there and all that kind of
stuff so
i'm down right at the very least it's
kind of cool to see that he got a name
but you know i don't really know what
significance that has on the nature
of the story right maybe just one of
those lost kingdoms that exist out there
that are not officially part of atlantis
but they just kind of exist out there
as kind of a side along to atlantis and
sort of do their own thing
again we're not entirely sure here but
another cool little thing that we saw
we got to see kamala khan using her
powers on set well i mean when i say
using her power is really more of her
just moving like she will use her powers
she's just pushing right there's not
really a whole lot going on there it's
really just kind of like the set pieces
but it is kind of cool kamala khan is
one of these characters where i'm
interested to see what they do with her
because there really is no middle ground
when it comes to kamala khan either you
love her or you hate her and a lot of
that is predicated on your ability to
identify with her
given the nature of her religion that is
very much rooted in tradition family
values but when you're living in the
states
family values kind of exist sometimes
in movies but we're not nearly as family
oriented as a lot of people in the
middle east
and so when you have that traditional
culture clashing with a lot of the
progressive cultural ideas that exist
here in the states
especially when you're a teenager trying
to fit in that can resonate a lot with a
lot of younger kids
but i imagine it can only really
resonate strongly if you can identify
with her character
having said that i'm not calling her a
lost cause one of the best decisions
that marvel ever made was putting her on
the champions which were basically the
young avengers but by like
a different name but it was still a cool
concept seeing her team up with sam
alexander nova and miles morales
spider-man i don't know if any s that's
really gonna happen but the point that
i'm making here is your ability to enjoy
kamala khan
is not really relegated to whether or
not you can identify with her being
a muslim pakistani american trying to
fit into american culture while
respecting her roots as far as being a
muslim from pakistan
i'm sure they'll make a lot of cool
jokes and they'll be like the young
angsty teenager vibe and so there'll be
a lot of cool moments in there that i'm
sure that you'll enjoy but i think to
really grasp the character you kind of
have to really be able to understand
where she's coming from but
you know at the end of the day i'm
excited to see it i love watching like
teenage superheroes
because there's just so much youth and
vibrance that's thrown in there
plus they're funny right like sam
alexander is nova is hilarious
he's a lot cooler than richard ryder was
richard ryder was boring as hell
i know i read him for 20 years
but moving on to our next topic and this
is probably one of the most significant
things
that we've heard of recently which
actually came out maybe about 20 hours
ago about yesterday as far as the marvel
cinematic universe what if series and
again
this is just a bit of a rumor here eric
killmonger and robert downey jr's iron
man
are supposed to team up what an odd
couple
but how awesome would that be
i loved the character of eric killmonger
i loved him in the movies
the only thing i didn't like about his
appearance in the movies is that in the
comics he defeated black panther
even when black panther had his powers
and that was designed to be a testament
to how
capable eric killmonger was i kind of
wish they'd carry that over to the
movies that eric killmonger defeated
t'challa even when t'challa had his
powers but i think they kind of had to
mix that out so they could basically
have the two of them fight on a more
even keel
when they both had the heart-shaped herb
at the end of the film but regardless of
the circumstance
i loved it right i loved eric killmonger
michael b
jordan is is probably one of my top
three favorite actors throughout
all of hollywood i've been following him
since the wire for those of you guys
remember how long he's been acting but
to see him and robert downey jr's iron
man team
up in the what if series which may or
may not be voiced by robert downey jr
sounds awesome man because those are two
characters who never met and i kind of
always wanted them to
there wouldn't really be a reason for
them to there wouldn't really be a
reason for like
you know iron man to show up in wakanda
and face off against eric killmonger
alongside black panther that'd be
something that you'd see if eric
killmonger had survived black panther
one and then became maybe a more
formidable villain or appeared in like a
different film
or something like that if we saw
something akin to like acts of vengeance
where loki gathered together
all these different villains and then
had them face off against all the heroes
but switched around who was facing off
against who so like red skull would
fight hawkeye
and like eric killmonger would fight
iron man and then maybe something else
would go on crossbones might fight black
panther i don't really know but at the
end of the day kind of switching them
around
that would have been a cool thing to see
but even if we're only going to see it
in in the form of an animated series
i'm excited for it man these two guys
meeting i can't be the only one
right i can't be the only one who's
excited at the idea of eric killmonger
encountering iron man right i'm sure you
guys are hyped for that too but
having said that guys this wraps up our
episode of the rumor roundup
let us know in the comments if there's
any important news bits that you think
we missed and we'll include those in
next week's video and i will catch you
all later
peace